Researchers have discovered a way to eliminate
cavity causing bacteria in candy by covering
it in more bacteria.
And in order to prove that chemical signals
can transfer messages - York University researchers
used vodka to send the world's first chemical
text message.
Vsauce, Kevin here.... this is Mind Blow.
This Swiss bank safe full of money is available
to be purchased and then moved and rebuilt
anywhere in the world.
It's the original bank safe from the Schweizer
Volksbank built in the 1912.
There are 1619 deposit boxes with original
keys and 8 million pieces of Swiss 5 cent
coins which is 15 tons of liquid money.
A 75 year old French man was given a revolutionary
heart transplant using a new artificial heart.
The Carmat artificial heart is expected to
operate for as long as five years and hopes
to give the patient the ability to live a
normal life until a real heart can be donated.
Unlike artificial hearts used in the past
it was developed to fully replicate the self-regulated
contractions of a real heart by using an intricate
system of sensors and microprocessors that
monitors the body's internal changes and alters
the blood flow accordingly.
Brothers Simon and Chris Parke are launching
their underwater jet pack.
The arm worn propulsion system uses digital
motors and wireless controls to operate.
Giving people a new way to explore underwater.
POE is an interactive urinal concept that
measures your pee... so yeah.
MetaPro is an augmented reality headset designed
to give you 15 times the screen area of google
glass in a pair of aviator glasses.
It mirrors devices such as smart phones and
laptops so users have them on the go at the
touch of a hologram.
For now there will be a cord attached to a
small computer you can fit in your pocket
and they're ready for pre order at $3,000
and plan to ship in July 2014.
The Temperperfect Mug is a smart mug that
allows the user to drink hot beverages at
the perfect temperature all of the time.
When the liquid inside is too hot the wall
of the mug takes out the excess heat and then
slowly releases it back into the liquid as
it cools keeping it at the ideal drinking
temperature.
Check out their kickstarter for more.
Engineers at Pacific Northwest National Laboratory
have created a way to turn algae into bio
crude oil in less than 60 minutes.
Wet algae is pumped into the front end of
a chemical reactor where the oil is produced
in under an hour.
The only byproducts are water and material
containing phosphorus, which can then be recycled
to grow more algae.
After production the oil can be converted
to be used as aviation fuel, gasoline, and
diesel fuel.
The SCHAFT robot is the winner of the DARPA
robotics Challenge of 2013.
They were given eight tasks to demonstrate
mobility, dexterity, manipulation, perception,
and operator control and they were created
to simulate acts needed in a natural disaster.
These include operating a vehicle, navigating
difficult terrain, climbing a ladder, clearing
debris, door manipulation, removing an object
from a wall, manipulating valves, and operating
a hose.
Researchers have developed a 3D modeling system
for babies with congenital heart conditions.
Since babies are unable to be put into conventional
3D scanners like MRI's doctors have relied
on echo imaging.
But now within five minutes they're able to
create a 3D image they're able to share and
use to explain to parents and other health
workers.
Finally "Pleiades" by Japan's Enra combines
projected light, animation choreography and
music...
I'm going to leave you with an autonomous
robotic dragonfly.
And as always - thanks for watching.